[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
XAVIER DUCROHET:
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I work on the
developer tools team.
AURIMAS LIUTIKAS: Hi,
my name is Aurimas,
and I am from
Android Toolkit Team.
Seems like everyone is
very awake, which is great.
Thanks for the attention
you guys are giving us.
Anyway, so we're going to be
talking about building bigger,
better, from a perspective of
a big Gradle Project, AndroidX,
and well as Android Studio.
We're here to hopefully dispel
the myth that you cannot build
big projects with Gradle.
So, every project starts
simple, but quickly,
as you add more
and more features,
it gets really complicated.
And from my work on Chrome
for Android and AndroidX,
formerly known as
the Support Library,
I learned that Android
projects are just the same.
They start as big monolithic
projects, they grow over time,
and each incremental
change makes sense.
For some context, over
the past six years,
AndroidX grew from 5
to 240 Gradle projects.
We went from 90,000 lines
of code to over 400,000.
We have an order of
magnitude, more commits,
writing all the cool
libraries for you guys,
like Jetpack Compose and others.
But as you can imagine, the
initial Gradle config just
couldn't keep up with this.
It was, like, not good
enough of a setup.
So, in this talk, we will
focus on how we made it better
and how we improved.
So, let me state the obvious,
when it comes to builds,
modularization is good.
You, first of all,
get more parallelism.
So, you are able to
compile multiple projects
at the same time.
You also get more
compilation avoidance
because Gradle is able to skip
certain libraries in cases.
For your fetches, you're often
invalidating fewer projects,
so you get fewer
cache invalidations.
Additionally, you avoid
tangled dependencies
that you get from
monolithic builds.
We definitely struggled
with that in AndroidX,
for libraries like v4.
We added dozens of classes and
there was circular dependencies
that made it almost impossible
to pull those libraries apart
into smaller pieces.
And finally, you get
to test your libraries
easier because now your
libraries live with the tests
next to them.
So, you exactly know what to
test when you make a change.
In architecture
components, for example,
we found that creating
pure Java libraries
as a common layer between other
libraries was really helpful.
First of all, you
get the separation
from Android APIs, which lets
you run those tests on a host.
Which is really fast, it's
not running on the phone.
Additionally, you
get faster builds
because by definition, these
non-Android, Java and Kotlin
projects are a lot lighter.
They don't handle variants.
They don't have
Android resources.
manifests and so on.
So, for your project,
if you can pull out
these kind of projects,
I would highly
recommend starting with making
them pure Kotlin or Java.
Gradle plugins can be great,
but overusing them can cause you
issues and wasted work.
For example, if you
have a Gradle plugin
for publishing to
Maven, you really
should be applying it
to the project that
needs to publish to Maven.
Otherwise, you're
creating all these tasks
and you will be wasting time.
So, modularization
here helps you
to apply these kind of plugins
to a much smaller scope,
so you're applying it to
a smaller project that
leads to faster builds.
Similarly to the plugins,
annotation processors
can waste time, especially
a nonincremental type.
For example, if you use
AndroidX Room Library,
you should really pull the
libraries that need Room
into a separate project, and run
the annotation processor just
on that project.
That way, you isolate on what
the annotation processor runs,
thus increasing your speed.
If your project
is an application,
you should really
consider running Lint only
in the final project.
Because while Lint is
amazing at finding bugs,
as you do modularization,
you're going
to be running it on more and
more projects, slowing it down.
However, I want to note,
if you do ship libraries,
I would highly
recommend continuing
to run Lint on those libraries,
because things like Minimum SDK
affect how Lint runs, and you
will return different results
and help you catch bugs.
We introduced the concept
of API and implementation
over two years ago.
It allows you to specify
your dependencies
as implementation details,
which, essentially,
helps with compilation avoidance
that I mentioned before.
If you want to learn
more about that,
there's a recording from
yesterday of the topic
that Xav did.
So, it's not all great.
There are some downsides
of doing the breakdown.
And one of the obvious ones is
you have a larger dependency
graph.
So, Gradle has to load
up more build files,
and figure out what's going on
and what the dependencies are.
But often, these are
offset by the fact
that you're doing a lot of
saving from all the things
that I described before.
One thing that is not so
easy and not so obvious
is that you have a lot
more build files now.
And this is one of the things
we struggled a lot in AndroidX.
A standard practice in
software engineering
is not to repeat
yourself, and the same
applies to build dot
configuration files.
Less code is simply
easier to manage.
In AndroidX, for
example, if you want
it to bump to a new
version of Espresso,
that meant touching a
hundred build.gradle files
and doing the same manual
change every place.
And it was really error prone.
It was really easy to make.
In a mistake.
So, these kind of
explicit versions
made it difficult
to upgrade, and also
was unclear of what versions
are used across the project.
So, one option to kind
of get around that
is to use Gradle's
extra [? stash, ?]
so it allows you to put
strings on this object.
And then you set it up in
your root build.gradle file.
Then, to utilize
them, you can put it
in each project as build.gradle
file and then, use it there.
The solves a
centralization problem
and makes it really
easy to update.
So, instead of having to
touch hundreds of files,
you touch it in one
place, and now you
have the updated version
throughout of your project.
It can be further
extended to use
this kind of extra property
for other things as well.
In AndroidX, we used this a
lot and it was very helpful,
but sadly, you do not get
things like autocomplete
and you do not get to click
through and see what version
you are actually setting.
So, to get around
that, there is a way.
Gradle offers you an implicit
build that gets automatically
added to the build class bath.
All you need to do is to
create a build source directory
and add build.gradle in
there, and that project will
automatically get built
before your real project,
and you will get added
to your build class bath.
So, solving the same
dependencies problem,
you can create a Kotlin
file in build source,
and just like in step one,
you have the same thing,
but now you're writing
it all in Kotlin.
And then, similarly,
you also refer to it
in your build.gradle files.
We eventually move to
this style to specify
all of our dependencies
in AndroidX.
It gives you the same
centralization benefits,
you also get autocomplete,
and you get the click through
to see the versions that
you are actually using.
So, in AndroidX, we found that
there's way more configurations
that we found the same from
build file to build file,
to build file.
And a lot of these were
coming from Android
to Gradle plugin,
and that Android DSL.
So, using extra property,
like we did in the beginning,
did not quite scale because
you cannot create things like
flavors and stuff very
easily at the root.
So, Gradle handles configuration
via plugin most of the time,
and you can create one of
your own in Build Source.
In AndroidX, we
created one of them
to set the common
properties that were
common across all the projects.
In this light,
the important part
is to override the apply method.
That's the one that gets called
when you apply the plugin.
And when you are
applied, you can react
when other plugins are added.
So, for example, if Android
Gradle plugin is added,
you can react to
it, and then you
can take the extension, which
is essentially the backing
store that you can use
in build.gradle files
behind the Android DSL,
and you can set things up.
So, one thing to note here,
you can have one custom plugin
that you wrote that handles
many, many external plugins,
you don't need to write
one for each plugin.
So, in this example, this
handles both, Android library
plugin and Android
application plugin.
And then, as you get up, you
just get automatically set up.
So, here, you have
the same power
as you had in Android
DSL in your build.gradle.
You can set things
like target SDK,
you can set the
default test runner,
enable coverage, and so on.
The two extensions that
you really care about
are library extension,
from the library
plugin, and app extension,
from the application plugin.
Same is true for other plugins.
So, for example, if you
have a Java library,
you can also configure
it in the same way.
The only difference,
here, is that you
have to use a convention
instead of an extension.
It's very similar otherwise.
So, when you have the setup,
it's super easy to apply,
and creating a new
module becomes trivial.
All your developers have to do
is throw in a few lines of code
and you're pretty much set.
So, in AndroidX, specifically,
which has huge gains of this,
we went from over
150 lines of code
for a build.gradle
for a project,
to around 35 lines of
code for build.gradle.
And considering we
have 240 projects,
that's a huge savings.
So, in our plugin, we set up
things like Maven configuration
for uploading, we
set up java.builds,
and Lint, and other
uniform properties.
Sadly, we hit an
issue where if you
want to do a custom
configuration just
to one library-- for example,
if one of your libraries
has a different
Minimum SDK version,
the setup didn't
really allow for that.
So, we needed to find
a way to accommodate
for this kind of change.
So, the first option is just
to set those custom values
in each library
build.gradle file.
In this example, we're
setting a different Minimum
SDK and different
target Java version.
And in AndroidX, we
did exactly that.
So, this is a real
example from lifecycle,
a runtime on build.gradle.
We simply applied AndroidX
plugin, Android library plugin,
we set up the
dependencies, and just add
some options for
Android DSL that
are specific to this library,
like, this library harshly
has ProGuard configs that we
want to ship inside of the AAR.
One difference here
is we also created
our own DSL that allows us to
tweak our own plugin works.
So, when our plugin
sets everything up,
it reads these
values and then we're
able to specify how our
Maven publishing works.
So, isn't it great to see
all of the configuration
for one real production
library in two slides?
I sure think so.
And Xav is going to
talk about how to set up
this custom Gradle DSL.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank you.
[AUDIENCE CLAPPING]
So, let's say you want to
configure your own extension
for your own plugin, right?
Let's take a very
simple example,
here, you have your
own plugin and you just
want to have my config
with one property in it.
So, here, I want to press
each one to be a Boolean.
Notice that I'm
using a setter here
and we're going to
see why in a second.
So, the first thing
that you need to do
is to create an extension class.
And this extension
class is very basic.
It doesn't need to extend
anything, and so here I have it
and I have my property.
So, notice two things.
The first one, I'm not
declaring a Boolean type--
I'm not using a Boolean type,
I'm using a property Boolean.
That is a new API integrator
that introduced maybe
about a year ago.
And the second thing
that you can notice here
is that I'm declaring
both the class
and the property as abstract.
So, those property objects
have to be instantiated
in a very special way.
And in order to
do that manually,
you have to inject a
factory into your class.
And it's really a
lot of boilerplate
that you don't want to do.
So, starting, I think,
two versions of Gradle
ago, if you declare your
classes as abstract,
Gradle is going to
take care of it.
Because, anyway,
what Gradle does
is that it never uses
your type directly,
it always extends your type
and creates a decorated version
of it.
And so here, when it
creates that new type,
it's going to take
care of instantiating
all the properties of
type, properties something.
So, the way you instantiate
it is just this way,
called Project Extension Create.
Aurimas's example had a
project extension, get by type.
So, here we create it.
The string is called my config.
This is what will
show up on your DSL.
And you provide your type.
The instance that
may fail to return
is not exactly
MyPluginExtension.
It's going to be the
decorated version,
but you don't have to care.
You can just keep
manipulating your own task.
All the things that's
added onto on above it,
you don't really have
to worry about it.
So now you want to
use that, you want
to use that value that
you set in the DSL
into a task as an input.
And so here, I'm creating a
task, and I have a property,
and I'm also setting
the type of the property
to be property of Boolean.
This is very important.
I'm also declaring
it as abstract
and the task also
type, instead of
being just a regular open
type that you would do,
I'm declaring it as abstract
so that Gradle can decorate it
and do the right thing for me.
Next, I want to
actually register
my task using the lazy API.
So register and a callback
that's a lambda that gets
called whenever your
task gets configured.
And here I am setting
on to my task property,
the property coming
from my extension.
I'm not setting the value.
I'm not doing myconfig.supress
LintWarnings.get,
if you do that, you lose
some of the benefits.
And so by using the
property directly,
you're basically doing a
lazy binding between the two.
So what happens is that this
code here, the register,
really is likely to
happen in your apply.
And your apply is at the
very top of build.gradle.
So if you change
the value later,
it's important that you do not
set the value in the apply,
because then if you
change the value later,
then the task will
have the old value.
So by using properties,
you guarantee
that whenever you're actually
configuring your task,
or whenever you're setting
the last value in the DSL,
at the end your task will have
the letter's value anyway.
So this is a new
feature of Gradle
and it's really efficient
and you should really
use property everywhere.
OK, let's look at other
tips to really configure
your project in the most
efficient way possible.
So when we talk
about configuration,
the first advice
that I have is really
do as little as possible.
I see a lot of people who do a
lot of things in their build.
They have 150 lines
in their build.gradle
and they do crazy
things in there.
And this is a cost you're
going to pay, all right?
Every time you go into
Gradle, whether you're
syncing, doing a build,
querying for the list of tasks,
you're going to pay that cost.
So it's important that you
do as little as possible.
Another advice is
try to see what
you can do that in release,
but not do it in debug.
You have those build
times by default,
we see a lot of people
doing way too much in debug
that they don't need to do.
Don't do it.
And then on CI, make
sure that you only build
whatever you actually need.
We see people calling
assemble, and that build is
way more than they need.
So around
configuration of tasks,
you know I just showed you
the tasks that register.
And it's particularly
important to use the lazy API,
because in Android, by default
you have five variants.
For each module, you
have debug, release,
and then three test variant.
So it creates a lot of tasks.
Here in the example that I have,
100 modules, it's 19,000 tasks.
You don't want to create
and configure all of them.
So we are already doing that.
What's important for
you is two things.
First, when you create your
own task, create them lazily.
And second, when you use APIs
from Gradle or from the Android
plugin, use the proper API.
There's a lot of legacy API
that returns a task instance,
and we have them in a GPU,
like, you know on your variants,
you can do get compiled, that
returns are compiled task.
If you use that, it's
going to create them,
it's going to force configuring.
Gradle has API that we
do on a task provider
and we have new APIs written,
get compiled provider, that
returns a task provider
that's a lazy object,
so you should use that.
The second thing I want to
talk about is task wiring.
If you're creating a
lot of custom tasks,
you probably have
to do some dependsOn
and that's very fragile and
really you shouldn't do it.
Let's say you have
A dependsOn B,
and then later you change
A to actually depend on C,
if you don't pay attention,
you may depend on B and C
and that's not what you want.
So the old way of
doing this is, you
have the Task1 to generate an
output directory and the type
of properties File.
And the Task2 that consumes that
directory and it has a property
of type File as well.
And so the way you
configure those two task
is, on the first one you do
register, output, my location.
On the second one,
you do inputDir=.
OK, so normally,
before, if you didn't
have a lazy configuration,
you could do Task1.outputDir,
you just link those
two locations directly.
You can't really do that
in lazy configuration.
So you have to kind of
either duplicate it or use
another class that's
centralized or your location
computation, which is something
we used to do in a GPU
a long time ago.
And then you do a
manual dependsOn.
So the first thing is not
great, then the second one
is definitely terrible,
you should not do that.
You might be thinking, well,
it's just the next line,
so if I update the
value of inputDir,
I will remember to
change the dependsOn.
But the reality is that it is
more likely to be somewhere
else at an integrated
plug in, it was definitely
in a lot of somewhere else.
And so we moved away
from all of that.
So, Gradle in the
last year, after they
introduced the property
type, they really
improved a lot of that.
So let's see what it
looks like and what's
the best practice today.
First your Task1, you're
going to change it
and the property is now going
to be DirectoryProperty.
And also, I'm using
also DirectoryProperty
on the second one
and, of course,
I used the abstract
way, so that Gradle
takes care of instantiating
all of those objects for me.
So DirectoryProperty
is very interesting.
It's actually a property
of directory similar me
out to the Property Boolean
that I showed earlier.
So it's dynamic and lazy in the
same way that the other one is.
But it also includes task
dependency information.
Even though, when you
look at the type here,
our key doesn't
really show anything,
but the Java doc says, hey,
it includes task dependency
information.
So let's see how I'm
going to use that.
Oh, and by the way, you see
that, it's actually directory.
There is a matching
regular file property,
so your API is more precise and
you cannot link to Task1 that
generates a directory, the other
one that reads a file anymore,
because it's type safe there.
So setting Task1, it's
very similar, outputDir.set
and then the value, so
no difference there.
On the Task2, what I'm
doing is, the same way
I did with the task
and the extension
earlier where I'm setting on
one property, the other property
directly to make a link between
them, I want to do that too.
But here, because
I have lazy tasks
while the obvious
easy way or lazy way
to do it is to say,
well Task1.get and then
I get the property.
Well it's not lazy
at all, actually,
because you got to first
configure your task, which is
not something you want to do.
So Task1 and Task2 are
a type of task provider,
and they have this
thing called flatMap.
So what flatMap does, it returns
a provider of a directory.
Provider being the
parent type of property
and it's a read only type.
And so this is lazy,
it's going to encapsulate
the property of Task1.
And it's going to propagate
the value in a lazy way,
but it's also going to
propagate the dependency lazy.
And so now, inputDir
automatically depends on Task1.
Sorry, Task2 directly
depends on Task1.
I don't have to do anything.
If I change input.Dir to be
set to a different value,
then it will automatically
change my dependency.
So when you extract flatMap
into an artifact of value,
that's very interesting,
because these thing, now,
represent the artifact and
whatever is needed to build it.
And you don't have to
care about the how, which
is keeping track of Task1 one.
So imagine you have a task
that output two things,
and you have some code
that use those two things.
And then later, you
change that task
to actually be two tasks
each that generate one thing.
If you're already
using the provider
of directory or provider
of regular file,
you don't have to care.
You don't have to keep
track of the task,
you just keep track
of this artifact.
And then you just read
it, it doesn't matter who
created it and it's updated.
This is something
that is very powerful
and that makes
code much cleaner.
This is something that
internally in Gradle plugin
we're moving toward.
And then I think
we'll expose that
as a public API at some point.
OK, so in my previous
talk, yesterday, we
talked about worker API.
Jerome talked
about it, explained
how things are less
efficient if you
have tasks that are not
using worker and tasks that
are using worker.
So please go look at the talk.
And the message for you today
is, if you have custom tasks,
please use the worker API.
Look at the API online
on the Gradle site,
it's not that difficult and
you should really do it.
Another thing that
I want to mention
is, when you create tasks,
always create a custom type.
It may seem easier to use
some of the API shortcut
that Gradle has, like you
could do something like that.
It's like, hey, I have a task
and I'm just configuring it
and saying here do this thing.
It looks OK, right?
And there's some trick
between the groovy DSL
and the [INAUDIBLE] DSL.
And you might be thinking
that it's the right thing,
but if you were to actually
use a default type from Gradle
and then tried to
extend it, you would
realize that
actually, you're doing
expensive call, whatever it is,
directly in the configuration.
So every time you
build, you're actually
going to do what your
task is supposed to do,
this is not good.
All right?
So the real shortcut would
now be Task doLast expensive.
So it doesn't look
as well, anyway.
And then doLast
cannot use workers,
you can't really declare
inputs or outputs.
And so the best practice is
always create your own type,
declare input, declare
outputs, and use workers.
If you don't do it, you're
basically not building
as efficiently as you should.
I'm not talking about doing
things during configuration
that you shouldn't
do, really we see
a lot of people trying to
do a lot of computation
and it's really not something
that you should be doing.
Now, I realize
that we don't have
awesome APIs to let you
do some of the things
that you want to do.
But I'm going to
run you through two
examples that kind of
explain some work arounds
to do a better job.
So the first one that is,
by far, the one that we
see the most people
do is putting
get information into their
versionCode or versionName.
So we see something like that.
VersionCode= and then calling
to get the [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever.
And it's just not
efficient at all.
Again, you're going to do that
every time you sync, every time
you call Gradle just to
do, hey, what's this task
or what's my dependency,
it is just not efficient.
So as I said, we don't really
have a better way to do it,
or a nice way, but there's
some ways to do it.
So the answer should always
be I need to do it in a task.
So here, because
it's not very easy,
the way that I found is, while
the versionCode is injected
into manifest merger, so if at
the end of the manifest merger
I go and I inject the
version, it should work.
So the solution
looks like this, I'm
going to run you through it.
So the first thing
is that you're
going to have to
read the versionCode,
and you're going to have
to read the manifest file.
And so since I'm
a little bit lazy
and I don't want to
use a full XML library
and find the attributes, I'm
just going to do a search
and replace.
So I said versionCode
to a lot of nines.
Hopefully, it's
not a string that
is present multiple
times in my file.
The next thing is, I need to
loop over all of my variants,
right?
You always have to do
it, if you did tasks,
you have multiple variants,
you have to deal with them.
And then also, the manifest
merger is part of the output,
because of multi APK if you use
splits and things like that,
here I don't have any, so I'm
just going to loop on them.
But I knew I would
only have one.
And then I use, I'm sorry, I
use manifest merger provider.
Remember earlier I said don't
use the known provider version?
So here, I get ManifestProvider
return a task provider,
and I can call
configure, which just
register a lambda
to run whenever
the task is configured later.
So it's lazy.
So inside, I added doLast,
I said earlier workers,
but that's the only
solution I have right now.
And then inside, it's very easy.
The first thing I do
is I read the manifest.
So here the manifest
merger actually
has a property
which is a directory
property,
manifestOutputDirectory.get
and then asFile.
And then I just read the file,
I do a search and replace,
and I write it back.
And if you do that,
it will actually work.
Now, there are some things that
you need to tweak a little bit.
Like if you do a get
comment touching,
let's say a read me file, your
get will want to exchange,
your [INAUDIBLE] want
to change, but your code
hasn't, so you need to
technically recompile.
Caching also is important
to use the inputs.
So you need to do a
little bit more work.
And so on tasks, you
can create new inputs.
So here I declare a new input.
The name has to be unique,
I put something random here,
and then you pass the value.
And again, it has to be lazy,
so don't put the actual value.
Put a callable that will do the
value so that Gradle can call
that whenever you need that.
The last thing here,
is that while I end up
coding compute value twice,
inside and during input
validation.
So you technically should
extract that into callable,
memorize it somehow.
And in fact, I should
probably put that one
above my application
loop, because I
don't want to do that for
both debug and release.
Some caveats here.
The model is not up
to date, so if you
have another plugin
that use versionCode,
it's not going to get the value.
Here I use a value as
an input, generally
you want to use a file,
but the input here
should be the get index,
which can be really big.
So do I want to do a
check sum of all of it?
Maybe using get, I can
get the value faster.
So up to you, figure it out.
And then doLast,
don't use Worker.
In fact, they don't use Worker
and they don't work very well
with Worker.
So if you have your task
here, and you add a Worker
at the end, if the task uses
a Worker, the doLast doesn't.
That means that if another
task run at the same time,
it can move doLast actually
and scale a little bit later.
So if you look at
Gradle scans, the time
of the action of the task
might be bigger than it seems,
but it is because of that
white space in the middle.
Something to think about.
OK, so we have
another example, which
is we see people passing
data via BuildConfig.
For example, they compute a
value and they put it there.
So here it's harder
to hook into the end
and actually add to the class.
So you can generate
your own class.
So in order to do
that, it's very easy.
You create a task, so
some inputs, package name,
class name, location,
and then the value.
And then the generation
is relatively easy.
I'm just generating your
following Java class.
So it's nothing to talk about.
The part that we want to
look at is how I register it.
So again, I loop
on the variants,
I create my task with a unique
name using the variant name,
and then I set the value here.
Again, using something lazy.
So project.provider
received a callable
and returned a provider object,
basically, so that it's lazy
and it's going to
work out of the books.
The last thing you
need to do is you
need to tell us that, hey, I
am generating some Java code
please go and compile
it or pass it to studio
so that I don't have
unresolved symbols.
And settle your API to do
that, receive task and not
task provider.
So we need to update that to
make that lazy task compatible.
So you would have to actually go
and call on your task provider
to get, which we configure it
right away, which is not great,
but it's better than
doing the computation
during the configuration.
All right.
AURIMAS LIUTIKAS: And I'm gonna
walk you through a little bit
through the guide
to investigations.
So how do you want to go
about profiling, measuring,
and optimizing your builds.
So Build Scans is
a really great tool
that is provided by Gradle,
the company behind Gradle.
It's really simple to use.
You run the same
tasks you normally do,
you just simply add
--scan at the end.
And it will prompt you
to accept a license,
and then it will upload
your results for analysis.
The important
caveat to note here,
this does send the
data to Gradle servers,
so you should be
comfortable doing that.
They do give you an option
to delete all the results
after you're done your
analysis, but you should just
be aware of that when
you're doing this.
Also, the reason why this
tool is really helpful,
it helps you find
those non-lazy tasks
that Xav was talking about.
And as well, you can find where
your dependencies that get
resolved during the
configuration time, which
is another big no no.
So in yesterday's,
talk if you saw,
Xav was talking about the
100 module baseline build.
And then this is how it
compares to AndroidX.
So this is a real project
that has 240 modules
and is able to configure it in
24 milliseconds for a project.
So if you're seeing your
builds of 40, 50 modules taking
10 seconds, 20 seconds,
there's definitely
ways to improve
and make it better.
So all I'm saying
is, get inspired.
So this is only 6 milliseconds
worse than a baseline project.
And one thing to note here,
that you can see in these lines,
that we're not even doing
them in any lazy task
configurations.
That just means that we haven't
done the work to actually make
it as fast as it can be.
So in AndroidX, we actually
use Build Scans in another way.
We used it to investigate
the effects of JVM max memory
limits.
We wanted to see how does
that affect our project.
And for our project,
it turned out
to be the biggest bang
for the buck potentially.
New studio projects start 1.5
gig limit for your Gradle JVM,
and that might not be
enough for your project.
So what you want to
do, is you really
want to run an experiment where
you try the different values
and see how that comes out.
In terms of to get the
optimal value of speed
versus memory usage.
The things you want
to do, you want
to run the --rerun
tasks that forces
you to run all the tasks.
Otherwise, you might be skipping
some tasks due to caching
and stuff like that.
And that will give
you incorrect results.
You want to kill daemons
in between the runs,
because if you don't,
the Gradle daemon will
stick around and cause
you memory pressure,
also leading to
incorrect results.
Another thing to
run, is you want
to run tasks that are
common to your developers.
So if your developer does
assemble debug all the time,
that's the path you
should optimize for.
And then finally, and
probably more importantly,
is you want to run it on a
typical developer machine.
If you're going to test
it out on a beefy machine,
and then developers are going
to run it on a different one,
you're not going to have
the same performance
characteristics.
So as you play around
with JVM memory limit,
you just want to use
build scans and see
how the execution time and
garbage collection times,
what the ratio is.
So here in AndroidX,
we did a scan
and it takes five minutes
to GC, and a total
build of nine minutes.
That means we're only doing like
four minutes of valuable work
and the rest of it is
just garbage collecting.
And that's bad.
That's the state we
were in before we
started investigating.
There's obviously hard limits
of how small the memory can be.
If you try to build AndroidX
or one gig of memory allowed,
after 14 minutes of
struggling, it will just
throw out a memory exception.
So as we did the test, you
can see in the graph, one
and two gigs were simply just
not a thing that you can do.
And at four gigs,
we're wasting a lot
of time garbage collecting.
We ended up picking
number 8 gigabytes for us,
because that was the best in
terms of the developer machines
that we had available and the
speed we were able to achieve.
As you can see, there's
diminishing returns
as you give Gradle
more memory, there
will be less garbage collection,
but you should really
pick a value.
And note, don't just
take 8 gigabytes
and set it in your project,
this is for our project.
You should do your own
experiment and run it yourself.
Another lever you have to
pull is Gradle workers.
So Gradle, by
default, gives you the
a number of workers as
you have processors.
And that might be too many
for you, because what happens
is the more workers you
spin up, the more memories
are being used at the same time.
And if you don't
have enough memory,
you force your computer to
go into garbage collection
all the time.
So potentially, limiting
the number of workers,
I know it sounds
counterintuitive,
but it might make
your builds faster.
And you essentially want
to run the same process
of experimentation that
we did for max memory.
And finally, one thing you
want to notice for your CI,
you probably should be
picking different values
for the maximum JVM limits,
as well for max workers.
And the reasons are, your CI
probably runs way more tasks
and different tasks than
what your build machines do.
And then also, you probably
have more beefier machines
with more CPU and more RAM.
And Xav is going to walk you
through how to use a tracer
agent to do more debugging.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
OK, so yesterday I
mentioned that you should really
profile your configuration.
Especially if you
apply a lot of plugin,
or if you have your own plugin.
So, of course, you can
use any Java provider,
but we found that
there was probably
a better way, a more user
friendly way to profile that.
So we created this little tool
called Tracer Agent that you
can go and download
from a repository,
you can build it, look at
the readme, see everything.
But, basically, it works
two different ways.
One way is you can create some
custom events using the API,
or you can just
attach it to your JVM.
It's going to run inside
it, and you provide it
with a list of
things to instrument.
And then at the end, it's going
to output a JSON file that you
can just load into
Chrome tracing tool
and see everything that happens.
So I did that with
the little plugin
that I made for this demo about
the manifest merger, doLast,
and the little generate code
for buildConfig and things
like that.
So what I did here
is I set it up
to instrument everything
in my custom package.
And then I added
a couple of lines
to instrument a few
methods from Gradle
to see some lifecycle between
configuration and execution
and a few of our
own methods in order
to also instrument
and see what's
happening in the Gradle plugin.
So you load that into Chrome,
and then you see all the colors
and you're wondering
what's happening.
So if we dig into the
configuration phase,
you see the large
green banner at the top
is the whole
configuration phase.
And then you can
zoom in and you can
see that this tiny
little line here
is the apply plugin
of my own plugin.
So I do very little here, great.
But then you can see that
you have these two lines
and if you look at the name,
it says customplugin.something,
that's my code too.
In fact, it's whenever you do
Android.applicationvariant.all,
you're just registering
callback to happen later,
whenever the Gradle plugin
creates those variants and then
call you back.
So it doesn't show up
in my apply plugin,
it shows up somewhere else.
That's why this tool is great,
because I say, show me where
that method is taking time.
Wherever it is, I don't
have to go and backtrack it
where it's coming from.
So here, it's called
twice and it's
the method called create
generate code tasks.
So that's my second example
that I showed about.
And it's taking a
large amount of time
compared to the whole pink line,
which is create another task,
and it's just for one task.
So what happens here is I let a
thread slip 100 milliseconds so
that it shows up there, but
basically you can go and really
look to see where your code is.
Another example, this is
during execution phase,
and again, you don't
really see anything else.
Not really should be
like a waterfall chart,
but here it only shows
you basically the end.
And it's my compute
version code.
So I can see that it's
called three times.
So it turns out that the
first two actually Gradle
are doing up to date checks and
calling the method to be like,
hey, what's the current version
compared to the old one.
And then the third
one is the execution.
And so I mentioned
earlier during my slide,
that you need to memorize it.
And here, obviously,
I did not do it,
and therefore I see
it run three times.
And so that's very useful.
So the good thing here,
is that you can basically
instrument any plug in.
If you apply a bunch of
plugin, go look at the source,
just open the JAR, see
what the package name is,
just add the package
name, it's going
to instrument all the plugin.
And then you can just
run a regular build,
look at just a JSON
file, see where
you're spending a lot
of time, and figure out
where your configuration
is way above the baseline
that Aurimas and I showed you.
I've talked to people telling
me I have a few dozen modules
and I have 30 plus
second configuration,
and this is not normal.
You should be way
faster than that.
So I highly recommend that you
use this tool or any other Java
profiler to really
figure out why
you're spending so much time.
And with that, thank you.
We will be at the Sandbox
if you have questions,
and thank you for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]